hey everybody it's Mike from motl uh
welcome to today's presentation you know
I'll get started in about 30 seconds
we've got uh we got a lot of people
registered today so I just want to give
them a chance to get in you know it's
been in a it's only been the first week
of of 20 2021 and you know it it hasn't
disappointed so to speak so um I'll get
started in about 15 more seconds you
know just waiting for the last people to
get in and then uh you know we'll get
things going so for those of you that
aren't familiar with who I am my name is
Michael Volos I'm the founder and Trader
at orderflows decom which is an
orderflow trading uh software and
education company I'll be joined today
with uh Pablo Mago from the indicator
store he's got a tool called markers
which is very helpful for Traders it
helps you automate um you know your
trade entry and and you know that's
important
because it's one of the things that a
lot of Traders struggle with often times
is getting into a trade you know they
they they hesitate right and you know in
trading the old saying you know he who
hesitates is lost you know that really
applies to trading just as into many
aspects in life and you know the to
markers which I first discovered many
years ago um back when we were still on
running ninja Trader 7 um you know sort
of solves that problem and it helps you
manage the trade now in automated
trading you know there's different ways
you can handle it you know I like to use
automated traded trading to get me into
the trade as quickly as possible right
so I'm not sitting there you know with
you know my dick in my hand so to speak
um you know should I be in this trade
should I not be in this trade if the
conditions are met it will get me into
the trade as soon as the conditions are
met and that's really what you want to
do is you want to get in as quickly as
possible if that's a trade you want to
do you know I I've seen so many Traders
struggle because they hesit hesitate
getting into a trade and you know that's
just getting into a trade you know
getting out of a trade obviously is is a
whole another um part of trading okay
and you know with markers you can
obviously set your ATM for your take
profit and your stop but you know you
could also manage it but for me the real
power the real strength in um you know
using a tool and using markers is to get
into the trade as quickly as possible
you know sometimes you know you just
look away from your screen for a second
and boom the trade sets up and then you
get in late right getting in late can
cost you um you know a few ticks and a
few ticks over course of a year add up
really quick and add up to a lot of
money so before before we begin you know
just a brief disclaimer please
understand trading involves risk um risk
capital is money that you can use
without jeopardizing your financial
security don't bet your rent money you
know don't take your oh my gosh you know
I just got my uh I just got paid and
this money's got to go to the rent oh
wait no I'm GNA put it in the market you
know some people do that you know as
crazy as it seems they go out and they
they they want to trade it you know they
sort of have this Race Against Time
don't have that mentality you know be
responsible
so you know last year
2020 was absurd um you know it's like
you know we going through 2020 and he
like oh it can't get worse you know back
in June oh things can't get bad as it is
now then you know September oh it's not
going to get worse you know then it gets
worse then after you know New Year's you
know sitting down with my wife on the
sofa after we the bringing in the New
Year well at least 2020 is over it can't
get worse yet six days into the year you
know gets worse um you know but the
markets have been resilient you know I
mean honestly it's
it's it's a lot of theater you know if
if there was really a coup do you think
the market would be continue making
alltime new highs um you know just bear
that in mind so sometimes it feels like
the the market has a a life of its own
so you know with that in mind what's the
agenda for today is I'm going to talk
about what the flow scalper tool is okay
and how it's going to help you in your
training the flow scalper is a new tool
that I released from order flows and it
reads the order flow I'm going turn it
over to Pablo he's going to talk about
markers okay what that is and you know a
bit about its background how to use it
Etc and then you know I'll take it back
and Pabo and I will talk you know why
you automate
trading and I'm going to take some time
take you through the steps on how to set
up flow scalper in markers okay so you
know by the time you come away you'll
understand what flow scalper is what
markers is whether or not you want to
automate trading um and more importantly
how to set it up in markers you know
sometimes you know a big problem people
have is they see a software okay and oh
this is great you know I want to get the
software then they get it they don't
know how to use it right and and that's
a big problem um it it leads to a lot of
frustration and it leads to a lot of
wasted time so you know that that's why
we're doing this presentation so get you
up to speed you know have a reference
for you that you can refer back to if
you're struggling getting something set
up you know it's honestly once you
understand how to get it set up once you
go through the steps then it it just
makes your life a lot easier so flow
scalper okay what it is is it runs on
ninja Trader 8 it's an indicator that
reads the order flow okay and you need
to enable tick replay on ninja Trader 8
um if you want to look at the Historical
um signals personally I was just having
a discussion with PA earlier you know do
I do I keep the tick replay on or off I
always have it enabled on on all my
charts just makes it easier for me
because you know I've got like 20 30
tabs open with different markets
sometimes I want to flip to another
market and see how it did you know
overnight or the day before and having
tick replay on solves that problem and
the flow scalper will work on a normal
Candlestick chart as well as an
orderflows Trader chart the footprint
chart and it'll work on minute based
charts range based charts tick based
charts volume based charts ha kanashi
kagi charts now it's not a footprint
chart okay so don't don't think that
even though I show you examples on a
footprint chart using flow scalper it's
sits on top of a footprint chart so
don't it's it's not a footprint chart
itself however what it does is it does
read the order flow data right what's
happening in the market right the you
know in order flow there's Delta
imbalances point of control right the
three main parts of order flow right and
obviously volume is a big important part
of order flow as well so what the full
scalper does is it takes all that
information and it generates signals
based on
um you know what's happening in the
market are buyers in control or are
sellers in control so you know the
problem that most Traders have is taking
those pieces of you know the orderflow
data points right the Delta imbalances
point of control volume and making them
work together and really you know the
flow scalper when I released I released
it last month you know even though I
still have a special introductory price
which will be ending soon um you know
been getting great feedback um you know
someone people have been telling me you
know the equity curve is nice and stable
on the results you know people are
telling me which Market they're they're
doing well in you know and what time
frames you know what type of charts
they're they're looking at and you know
it's been it's been nice it's been nice
to see so many people being helped now
if there's one piece of advice I give
you in trading is just follow the money
right period you know people say oh you
know I got to look at this indicator I
got to look at that indicator no you got
to look at what's trading in the market
okay and don't over complicate trading
right just follow the money and you know
sometimes you know people think they
they're they're smarter than everybody
else you know let me ask you you know do
you think
you're you're smarter than the whole
Collective at JP Morgan or the whole
Collective at you know Goldman Sachs
probably not you who knows you might be
you might be you know a
a genius or something but you know most
often than not those are the people that
you are competing against okay
and you got
to you have
to understand that you could have sort
of the best level the best um way of
analyzing the market but if the money
that comes in
after you get into a trade isn't there
to confirm it it's going to be a loser
right and you know flow scalper is a
tool that is going to help you you know
even if you're in a position confirm
that yeah this trade is going to keep
working right and and that's that's the
problem that you know a lot of Traders
struggle with is they they they get in a
position and once they're in the
position as far as they're concerned
that's it okay it's either going to go
to my stop or it's going to go to my
takeprofit and there's no middle ground
well there is Middle Ground and that's
where um you know Traders can Excel is
reading what's happening after you get
into a trade you know if I get long you
know e min's at a certain price
3801 and goes up 3801 3802 3803 all of a
sudden bearish flow comes into the
market at
3804 then back down at the three and a
half at two you know based on what I'm
seeing in the order flow can tell me to
get out of the trade you know I don't
have to sit there and say oh okay well I
got my fourpoint stop so if it comes
down to
3796 I'm out okay but why why wait for
it to stop you out if what you're seeing
in the orderflow all of a sudden has
changed okay that's what make orderflow
Traders different than normal
indicator-based Traders okay they're
following the money they're
not the following the math so to speak
you know that's most indicators are
math-based in the sense that you know
they they come from some mathematical
equation and you know that's all well
and good you know in in things you know
in certain industries but
mathematicians aren't Traders you know
in the P you know Fibonacci wasn't a
Trader um you know a lot of these guys
weren't Traders so you know basically
what you're trying to take is you're
taking something that was developed 3
four 500 years ago and applying it to
the market because it looks nice and it
looks like it's working
well you know I can go outside and and
take a picture of the the branches on
hanging on my trees put it up on a chart
and say oh yeah when when the market
came down to this branch that was
support and it rallied up and I'm going
to Overlay that every time I I you know
look at the market that's that's not the
that's not trading
so orderflow follows the money okay so
when you look at a Candlestick chart
where do you think that information
comes from well right it comes from the
time in sales okay and that's where
you're going to see the order flow so
you know let me just pull up a chart
here
okay this is okay so I'm going to be
flipping around you know between a
normal bar chart okay and a footprint
chart okay so this is a footprint chart
this is yesterday in the e- minis okay
and you can see there's a lot of
information you can see the volume
traded on the bid the volume traded on
the offer um you know where there's
imbalances you can see you know Deltas
if they're positive they're negative
again I'm not going to make today you
know a whole class on orderflow but
there's so much information you're
seeing on this chart that you don't see
on this chart right a normal Candlestick
chart just tells you oh yeah the bar
opened here traded down here traded up
there then it closed you know up or down
yeah that's that's great um but you
really missing out
on the whole point of of trading you
know and
this is where you know if you've ever
run a business okay you understand how
important volume is you know and that's
sort of one of the reasons why I think a
lot of Traders struggle is is they sort
of disregard volume okay they sort of
relegate it because they haven't been
able to figure out how to use it
basically you know you have these great
scientists you know rocket literally
rocket scientists you know getting data
right guys doing their PHD pulling up
data over the last 50 years but they're
just looking at price in the market
they're not looking at volume so they
don't have context of what was trading
at a price and if you've ever run a
business you know you understand
that if you have if you're selling a
product and demand is such you that's
going to adjust you know what demand is
doing it's going to affect how you are
going to um you know price something and
when and how you price something is
going to is going to affect how much of
the products sells right so you're
always dealing with supply and demand in
relation to price you know if price gets
too high people you less people are
going to buy if it gets too low more
people will buy and that's going to
affect you know if you're running a
business that's going to affect your
profits and and losses so you know it's
something that you know as a Trader you
need to keep in mind and you know and
understand
so without getting into you know sort of
the minutia right there's the orderflow
scalper just really quick is reading all
this information in the bar right what's
going on in the order flow in that bar
you know relative to previous bars and
let me just open up the settings
here and basically it distills it into a
few choices right you have a choice of
you know do you want to have signals
generated you know at swing highs or
swing lows or anytime signal is
generated um you can adjust you know
volumes like do you want to see signals
when only if there certain amount of
volume has been met you know if it's
been you know 200 contracts traded in
the bar um if you're looking at
something you know a thin Market that
may be applicable but if you're looking
at most markets it's not you know when I
say thin markets you know I'm talking
about some of these markets that not a
lot of people trade some of the grain
markets or oil seeds things like that
the smaller markets
um the
normal the normal order flow strength
this is the most important one you're
going to deal with next is contango now
this contango one as people a bit
confused you know different markets
trade in different ways based because
they they're physically settled or
they're cash settled physically settled
means it's deliverable cash settled
means um it settles and you know any
difference is Cash settled into your
account whereas you know something like
a grain market or an oil Market you know
depending if you're long or short you
got to make delivery or accept delivery
um so those type of markets have you
know slightly different characteristics
okay and that also has a strength that
you can adjust now typ
markets depending on how what Market
you're trading you know and the time of
day
because what type markets is you know if
you're trading e- minis at night versus
e- minis at day during the day right
right you can see at night time you're
going to get a lot of bars you know this
is a one minute chart a lot of bars at
night time that you know maybe four or
five ticks big you know but during the
day you get you only get a few of them
right but at night time you get a lot of
those and you know some bars that are
just basically trade the bid in the
offer for how many minutes that's where
tight markets comes in you know if if
you're trading the night time and you
want to analyze those markets those type
of bars as well
but you know normal bars it's fine you
know if you're trading during the day
you in contract like the e- mini you
don't have to really use that but if
you're trading in the night session that
takes into account sort of the
volatility of the market in the sense
that you know it doesn't move around as
much so it's trading in a tight tighter
range now you could have a sound alert
you just have to take that and you could
just drop your own sound alert in here
now
one other quick thing is the trade entry
signal now one of the reasons why I
first got interested in markers was
because I needed something that could
help my trading get me into a trade so
um you know when the order flow
was uh conducive and what that means is
say say as you know the conditions are
met here in
this in this bar here at 1055 okay I
like to let the market take me in okay I
like the next bar to open up and start
moving in that direction okay I want it
to start moving by two ticks right so if
I have a long signal I want the next bar
to open up and start trading at least
two ticks before it generates this Buy
Signal that's what this trade entry
signal is now there's two points to this
there's trade validity in bars and
there's trade price level two is this
next bar has to move by at least two
ticks and it has to happen within two
bars so what that means is bar this is
the signal bar here at 1055 so either in
the next two bars it has to start moving
by at least two ticks if it doesn't then
there's there's no
trade so what's happening is if you
don't have trade entry signal in this
signal bar is where the signal would
appear now with the trade entry signal
it's only going to tell me it's only
going to take trades if this signal bar
has the signal and then the next bar or
two starts moving in that direction that
cuts out a lot of bars that I don't get
the the followup order flow right and
that's going
to affect my trading right because if I
get long but the rest of the world
doesn't agree that yeah you know
everything's turned bullish like I said
follow the money right if everything
came in here you know at the swing low
and everything was bullish and yeah it
looks like there's a great buying
opportunity okay but you know if the big
Traders also don't agree that there's a
buying
opportunity the Market's just it's not
going to go any higher and eventually
it'll just sell off and fall over and
you know will stop you out you know this
keeps me out of not all the bad trades
but it keeps me out of a good portion of
the trades you know it keeps me out of
the trades that don't work out so you
know I've I've gone through a lot of my
past signals and and past trades and it
keeps me out of about 45% of Trades
that um I shouldn't be in right so
imagine you could cut out 40% of your
losing trades what do you think that's
going to do to your bottom line so all
these settings right well I'm going to
show you later I'm going to turn it over
to marker uh Pablo in a in a minute but
all of these whoops here it is all of
these these settings right
here you put it into markers plus I use
markers copy to generate my signals and
do my auto trading and you know that's
what's going to you know enter the
trades for you so whatever I have set up
on
here I automate that all right I
automate the trade entry and obviously
it'll have my ATM strategy you know you
should have several different ATM
strategies depending on the markets you
know one other quick thing markets at
night markets during the
day generally
trade differently in the sense that you
know I could use the same settings on
Flow scalper at night as I use during
the day but my take profits are going to
be are going to be lesser right it's
going to be different because you you
don't get as many moves at night as you
do during the day that are you know the
the normal rotations um so anyway with
with that in mind I'll turn it over to
Pablo now just give me a sec and you
know and he can take you through markers
so let me just find you here
Pablo hello
everyone this test okay yep I could hear
you okay I can show my
screen
per um which screen
okay I see a screen with uh the
Amazon no not this way
okay
one okay now now you can see charts
perfect hello everyone first of all
happy New Year H hello Mike thank you
for for this opportunity to show the
tool and by the way I have a lot of
customers asking about about how to H
automate your signals so that means that
you are very
successful congratulations thank you so
let's take a look because what I am
going to explain today is useful not
only for flow scalper but also for Delta
scalper and a lot of your indicators and
another third party
indicators first of all the the main
difference that you were explain
in today about the thck replay the three
charts that we can see now are the same
and the only one different is this
one that has the last
option this one the trade entry signal
is turned off and this is the only
difference this chart this chart is
painting signals
that while the B is moving sometimes
they are
deleted and for example all the
triangles here all these
signals are part of this because as Mike
explained here we
wait for two ticks move because here the
option I guess it is two
things uh yes two ticks so we must move
two ticks in the direction of the signal
for for example uh here I have a short
this one and there was a move two ticks
below and this this move but the signal
is painted H when that already happened
because we are two ticks into the
direction of the trade so this signal
this one is painted here h
and also that means that once this
signal is painted it is no longer
deleted so I can read the signal and
enter the market intrabar at the exact
moment this signal is painted which is
not at bar close and this signal is
painted
intar when Market goes two ticks in the
direction of the first
signal so here with the same indicator
we have two different ways to trade we
can trade these
signals or this ones both both signals
are painted in trar and the only
difference is that on this chart when
the market moves then we can I will try
to make a playback so we can see how it
works but the signals that we can see
here are painted and deleted so maybe I
I entering the market and then the the
signal is deleted instead the signals on
this chart once they are painted they
remain and again they are not painted at
we close so my entry on this signal is
not at the
close usually it is when I am two ticks
into the direction of the market and if
we have time I I I will do a playback so
we can review that and what we have on
this chart is this chart is a copy of
this one the only difference is I did a
refresh and when we do a refresh if I
don't have this option The Tick replay
this is on data
series and there is a good video of mic
on how to enable this option if you
don't see that option on your chat so
this is for historical if you enable
this option
when you reload npt or add an indicator
or change anything on your
chart ER everything is recalculated
again tick by tick no bar by bar so
depending on the number of days that you
have on your chart and the number of
indicators that calculate th by this may
take some
time instead on this part I have H the
replay Ena so even if I do a refresh I
uh this indicator on this on my computer
because this is a an old
notebook and I have three days on one
minute NASDAQ and it is taking more or
less 15 seconds
15 but take into account that if I copy
the signals
then I have another 15 seconds and if I
copy the long and then I copy the short
I have 15 seconds
and total more or less one minute so I
am not going to refresh this
chart but uh at the end of the session
uh at the end of this explanation I I
will show you a trick
to don't not use H pick replay and also
get the signal pained only on playback
when we are testing an instrument and a
setup we use playback and we can get all
the signals not using th
replay but now let let's go to the to
the how to how to automate this and we
have two different
signals
so on on this chart whatever I place on
this chart is not going going to be
painted unless the market moves because
we if we connect now to something that
moves at a f that moves from this bar to
the right all the signals will be
painted because the the indicator Works
real
time that means it is not necessary to
have thck replay enabled to trade the
signals it is necessary to view the
historical signals what we have here for
a visual back test this is a really this
is really helpful but for light trading
if you want a fast control of your
computer H you want to change something
and have an instant
result uh my suggestion is try to
disable that
option and okay for visual testing you
can enable the the tick replay but don't
forget that while the tick replay is
working
most of the chart with the same
instrument are not
working so be careful with that if you
are trading
line so let's try to work with this
chart
okay and let's see if I remove all I
have the two
copies and if I click on okay everything
will
be we have a refresh calculating this is
on thck replay so it it will take about
15 seconds to finish
this after they finish we have we have
the signals
perfect these signals are plots we can
click on the middle button on the mouse
and we can see that this indicator has
four plots and most of the signals are
the first
two we can also see the plots on the
indicator parameters at the
bottom and this are the plots that we
need to copy on this
example and using the same parameters
because if I change one of the
parameters the copied signal is not
going to be the same than the
painted signal by the indicator and also
we must check that if the indicator is
working at each thck we must copy at
each
th so having said that we go to Markus
copy assign a name for my signal for
example go
long and go long for example is already
used on this chart h so on this case I
am going to use the instance number two
so I can duplicate names
or on the same
instrument now this is a fast signal
perfect and on input series I need to
place this indicator with all the same
parameters so we click
here
indicators um or the flow scalper
and I I don't remember the settings so I
have a screen
capture
here okay it is
not okay so again input cing
is order
flow flow scalper the same parameters
one
Z
1 and this option is enable that means
that the signals painted are confirmed
they are painted in trar and
confirmed and I want to copy the normal
by
the blue this blue
triangles
okay now also very important ER this the
indicator works at each pick so I need
to
copy at each
P and the mark copy paints a little dot
that we use as guideline and we can
change that shape and also we can hide
that dot but this is important just to
check that what we are copying is the
same that we are watching on the screen
so if I click on okay now we need to
wait the indicator and then the copy so
twice the
time and we can see here it is
calculating and if we have more charts
on the same instrument they are not
moving NE they taking
orders okay now we have an
indicator and can you see a little
dot check if we can yes now now it is
visible a little dot over the triangle
so we can check that the copy of line is
equal to the um to the real
signal and now we can s select copy and
right click
copy H
paste I have not copy so I can click
copy click
again
paste I need to wait again another 15
seconds or maybe a little
more this is just to avoid having to
copy all the parameters again I just
copy and paste and and then I only need
to change the plot one of the parameters
so I go to indicators now I have two
copies two copies and both are exactly
the same because I copied and pasted so
I I only need to change on the second
the name of the signal go
short or whatever you
want uh and on input series we need to
select the other plot
instead of normal by normal short all
the parameters are
already okay because I I I did the
copy okay and now we can change the
color to
red and if I click on okay then we need
to wait for the indicator and for the
copy for Longs and the copy for shorts
okay now we have the indicator now we
have the copy for Longs and the copy for
shorts and we can see the the
dots if this is just for for checking
that we are
doing correctly everything if you don't
like the dots and there is a parameter
to disable that painting on the copy you
can turn off this option now take a take
a look at this we copy a plot from an
indicator we assign a name as a fast
signal because we have this option enabl
and we are copying the horizontal offset
is zero is the current
bar I can type a one so we copy the
previous one that means here I am
copying real time because this is
working real time whatever is painted by
this
plot that means that if the signal is
painted at the same tick I execute an
order because I canot go to
markers which also works on
intrabar
always I other markers by default and
please never change that markers works
at each
TI and I need to instead of looking for
drawing object which is a slow process
we can change to fast signal and type
the
name of the signals that we created with
copies and on this case these two
copies are using an ID of two because on
the other chart I I am already using
those signals and I don't want them to
get
mixed oh these markers is reading go
long with the ID number
two and that's all if I click on okay
again I need to
wait but if I turn the thck replay off
it is going to work anyway there's no
difference
now let me we need to finish to wait to
finish
this let's see what happens with the
other option because this is
important
okay H the final step H we have the
signal painted by the indicator the copy
of signals and we also have the markers
toolbar now if I want to automate this I
need to open chart
Trader select an
ATM click here select an ATM select an
account I am disconnected now but select
an account and then click here if you
are on playback the account name is
different then enable the loans enable
the short
and switch to semi-automatic or
automatic semi-automatic tra only
following signal and then the button
turns
off H this is useful if you are waiting
for a short for example but only the
following short because you want to have
to be in control then you can enable the
shorts switch to
semi-automatic and as soon as we get a
signal painted it enter shorts with your
selected ATM and the button is turned
off but if you want to trade all the
signals you can switch this to
automatic we have a lot of more options
on markets we can add filters we can add
exit
conditions ER we have for example money
management like for example by default
we have a maximum daily profit of 500 if
we reach that number or exceed that
number either positive or negative then
we get a s message here here that says
limits are reach and no more trades for
the day and this is also something
important if you are going to full
automate your set
up also we have entries the the default
is enter at Market but you can place a
bu stop over the over the bar or a by
limit below the price action but more
about that you can go to
my teach training sessions all tday they
are free or watch my
videos and yeah we have more option like
for example the time window I can
specify which time to start which time
to stop or I can type two time which
windows and trade the morning trade the
afternoon anyway this is a way to
automate those signals now what happens
with the other
configuration because there are several
indicators on the
market that uh work like this like this
indicator
with this configuration we have the
confirmation option disabled so the
signals are painted early one bar early
but they can be deleted when the bar
closes and we can try later to see them
working with
playb now uh with this option turn
off we can see that on the copies
everything is the same but I am looking
at the previous bar why
because ER what the triangles that we
see
here were painted and painted and
finally when they were finishes they
remain or not but if we if I am copying
real time all the triangles maybe I I
get triangles everywhere and this is
what happens if I don't use a one let me
show you
everything everything else is the same
because the the pro the procedure for
the copy is exactly the same the only
difference is that on input cus when I
copy the indicator this option is not
enabled and now if instead of using one
so you can see that I have a delay the
signal is one bar late because I I am
looking if my previous bar
as a signal still
painted if I use a
zero then I get a signal every time a
bar had a signal even if it was
deleted see if it takes too
much now this
calculating I I can remove this now
may maybe sometimes we want to execute
those kind of order even even if they
are later
delete now we can see the signals that
remain painted are the triangles and the
copied signals are where we have a DOT
that means that this bar for example
with a blue dot
had a triangle at some moment and then
it was
deleted and it was deleted because there
was
no advance in the following bar two
ticks in the same
direction um same same on these two
these two had a triangle and then remove
it so
now let's try to do a playback and also
I will show you a method to get the
signals painted without using thck
replay so this is a moment where maybe
my ninja
crashes so just to take into account I
will close this
workspace and open this one with no
thick
replay no I don't want to say nothing
okay here I have only one
chart the take replay is not
enabled and the
indicator on this example is using the
confirmation method this one so the
signals on once they are painted they
are never deleted
now if I want to test this I can connect
to
playback and this usually fails and in
my case in my computer it usually fails
and even more if I am
using H pick
replay okay let's go to ah the the new
release of nja Trader
from 8.22
and later have this option when you
right click the the playback you have
three different
options nin ninja 7 worked this way from
selected that means if I click on go to
uh January 5 at 5
a.m. am if it works
I I need to wait this to be green I get
an instant chart at 5: a.m. but the
signals are not painted because it is
not calculated it is
painted on historical mode same as it
worked on Nisha 7 and also on previous
versions of Nisha trade below
22 but now if I click on current day
and now I click on go to and I don't
change this I I leave the same date and
time what I get is a playback a fast
playback of all the day to the time that
I am working so the result is I get the
signals painted tick by tick they are
the real thing and you can see the the
effect if I reload n just script
everything is
gone so this is my trick for the
day if you want to if you are doing
playback and you want to check your
signals then this is a way to do a fast
playback but now when you want to
test it is faster to click from
selected so if I click on
play ah I need to
select
automatic I need to select an ATM and I
need to select the account is already
set but if you wear on Sim and then
change it to playback don't forget to
change the account now if I click on
play from the current bar it will start
painting signals and also it will
execute those
signals we can go faster
I guess we can go even more faster there
should be a signal more or less yes here
I have a
[Music]
signal that was a trailing stop and I
can go
even faster
okay so if you want to do something
fast you can leave the de play turn off
there there's no difference in the
performance of the real time because the
real the real time is not using this
option but this is for you because if
you change something for example if I
have a indicator now H I don't know
anything
this when I click on okay all the
signals are
gone they are no longer there because
the indicator needs a intar data to
calculate but I can do the trick this to
disable because I don't want to
execute and play all the corrent day now
go to don't change nothing click
okay and now I get again all the
signals and I guess that's all I covered
all the possible ways
[Music]
to to execute and let me show you the
other because
maybe let's change the the other method
let's change the the signals to not use
this
perfect and also we need to change the
copies to not use
this the same for the
other not use
this okay
and I don't need
this
okay all the signals are gone so I can
do the same trick again go to
okay and now the the movement is too
fast so we cannot see the signals
painting and painting but we can
decrease the speed
and take a look at the at the
signals let's go just a little
faster can you see the triangle is gone
but the dot remains because it was
painted same here the the triangle was
painted I have a signal and maybe if I
am executing this order I am entering
long on this case it was good H same
here I have a short there was a short
painted and there was a short
detected so if the market keeps going to
the upside this is a fake detected
signal like like now so how can I Sol
that need to copy the previous
bar the copy I select one
B so yeah I am sure that the signal
remains
one
okay it is off so now let's go again
okay and
now I have a triangle confirmed triangle
confirm it and now let's see how it
works enable
rantic and
play when I when I see a triangle there
is no signal because we wait on the
following to the following
bar here I have a triangle it is deleted
again
painted now I have a blue triangle
possible long if at the following bar it
remains no it is not
remain now a possible long no it is
deleted now and the triangle
remains it was detected and executed
there are there are a lot of ways to to
trade this ER because you can also have
the option to execute all the
unconfirmed signals and instead of enter
at Market just place a buy stop order
over the bar so if the market moves in
your direction then you enter the market
if a certain number of bars you don't
the market is not going in that
direction the order is Canal
okay I I I guess I have covered
everything not sure if there are any
questions uh yeah Pablo um stay on
there's there's a few questions maybe
you can that are kind of directed at you
um let me just see here because a lot of
questions starting to come in now
[Music]
um uh let's see okay okay here
good question is where is it this these
things keep scrolling people are asking
questions just bear with me
um was it the filter someone asked about
a filter if you can show an example how
to set up a filter yeah very
simple and That's a classic let me clock
this
position because I have a lot of signals
from this system or any other system lot
of ways to uh Define filters one the
slope of a line very good a classic
example for example I don't know maybe a
linear
regression whatever you have on your
indicator list can be used it as a
filter I like the linear regression
maybe you have something
else I I from the linear regression I
like to look not the position of the
price versus the line but the
slope and I can calculate the slope of
that line with one of the tools that is
included with markers markers is not
just marker plus and markers includes
all these tools one of them is the
marker slope so I
can assign a name for my slope for
example my
slope and I want to measure the slope of
this line which is a linear regression
so on input series I look my
indicator linear
regression and on this case is
83 by by default it is painting um
signals but I don't need a signal each
time there is a change on the direction
so let's turn this
off because I I'm only interested in the
histogram when the line is sloping up
this is positive when this line is
sloping down it is negative that means
when this is positive I want to enable
Longs when this is negative I want to
enable
shorts so
now the name I assigned for this is my
slope and I can use this on
markers enable
filters and I have a limited number of
conditions I can add as many as I want
but in this case my condition is that
this histogram must be greater than zero
or for example greater than one or 0.5 I
can add a threshold but let's make it
simple greater than zero
positive and for
shorts maybe I want it to be less than
zero negative 0.5 or make it
simple less than
zero okay
okay
now I have a new button here where I
have the
filters and the result of the filter is
here waiting for incoming data so we
need incoming
data and now Longs are enabled because
the histogram is blue shorts are
disabled when the filter is
on H if I get a short signal it will be
ignored if I want for some time disable
the filter I can turn the filter off I
don't get the results
here and for example this is just one of
the simplest case but I can look at the
position of a moving average against the
faster moving aage or anything or having
two green bars two consecutive green
bars the rules are unlimited you can
choose any any filter you
want okay okay okay um one other I think
you've answered it
already it was a question about two
arrows red red or blue up here after the
closing bars again that's I I know Pablo
covered that a bit um you know there's
different ways you can use flow scalper
to generate a signal now you know
remember with order flow as a bar is
forming it can there can be a signal but
if the order flow in that same bar Camp
comes in and is contrary to what the
signal is the the signal will disappear
as the bar is forming once the bar
closes the signal will appear there now
if you're using the trade entry
signal the bar has to close period
before signal will be generated I know
Pablo covered that and I think uh I saw
a comment from the same person said uh
thanks for covering it Pablo um there's
another
question uh will it work on range charts
yeah it'll work on on range charts and
most people I
mean I don't know in my experience I
find about half the Traders use time
based charts the other half use sort of
a combination of range based charts
volume based charts it really depends on
you know how you of approach the market
um let me see here someone says this
sounds crazy complicated actually the
first time you know I thought the same
thing but then you know literally after
sitting down and and watching some of
Pablo's videos you know you got to take
the time to want to learn a new tool um
it took me about you know and and I'm
not a computer person um you know that's
one of the reasons why people say oh why
don't you use Sierra charts you know you
can do so much more than than ninja
Trader I
am I'm I'm like an average computer
person okay and and I find that you know
ninja Trader is is good in what you can
do and it just takes a little time to
learn it okay it's not going to take a
month to learn you know really I want to
show you guys how I set it up from
scratch um in a minute um Sally asked
would it be easier to get a template
yeah templates are easy but I find
creating it yourself you know when you
understand what you're doing um makes it
a lot easier now
Pablo there's a question for you um RB
asks what's the purpose of copying okay
because like in your in markers there
there's a lot of different choices of
you know there's copy there's um slope
Etc maybe you can explain that a little
bit yeah sure the the copy is the main
feature of markers because any anything
that we have on the chart signals
lines H whatever we can copy that into a
markers variable and then we can access
that market variable to do something for
example that market variable is greater
than the same on the previous bar or has
a value for example when when you have a
signal the market variable has value or
not because when there is an empty space
like now the market variable has no
value at all uh so yes you can do a lot
of things for example detect the
crossover between two lines for let's
say that you want to detect the
crossover between this and the price one
way to do that is uh to
copy the line and then detect the
crossover between the name that you
assigned to this to with the
price and yeah it may it may looks
complicated because you you may say why
not saying creating an indicator where I
can directly place the name of the
indicator here for example on one of the
parameter because it is not possible it
is not possible to to create create an
indicator where I can place more than
one data
series here on input series I am copying
the order flow and so on the on this
variable I am placing the value of the
plots painted by this indicator it will
be much better if I can detect the
crossover if I have two two input series
but this is not possible on at l on the
current version of n
tra okay okay um thenit ask Pablo how do
set markers plus so that it only takes
one signal and not every signal
following the First
Signal you have several options
and well I I was going to do a
demonstration of that today because for
example this
indicator as it is conf now it pains and
un pains pains and un pains so it is
possible that I can I enter the market
and I get the Target and then it pains a
triangle again because we see a solid
triangle now but the indicator is
painting repainting and
repainting sometimes and then it and
sometimes it is also deleting the
triangle so we have the option look look
at this now we have another triangle but
we are in a trade so we have the option
to take only one trade per direction or
ER I I I I don't know
um imagine that you have small target
has two ticks then you have an entry
take two ticks and that's all but on the
same bar you have another signal painted
and you you can take enter again on this
same signal and you have entry Target
entry Target entry Target right that
option is here I usually don't like to
take more than one trade per side but
this is
optional
here one trade per bar so if you got a
signal on this bar and you finish it
with Target or stop it doesn't matter uh
no more signals are taken into account
and all the rest of the signals are
ignored but if you untick this option
and you finish the trade you can enter
again this is hard to visually back test
because you have no idea looking at the
chart how many entries are on a
bar that's like something if you are
trading on a a dome or something you
know and you're you're you're really
scalping in a more pure sense or you're
taking a lot of Trades U that that back
up real quick um the indicator setting
for
markers yes um because I wanted to ask
you take a second to explain um
something there
the first of all first we need to we
need to copy the signals right so we go
to Mark
copy and we need to set this as a f
signal we assign a name
and on input series we look for the
indicator currently flow scalper we set
all the
parameters and then we select which one
of the plot is the one I want to copy
currently I am copying the normal by the
blue
triangles and also the copy must
work on each sck or at bar clock
depending on how the original indicator
is working if your indicator was working
at bar close the suggested method is
coping at work clo and to avoid
overloading the computer yeah actually I
use on on each check but um can you go
to the markers plus the force um I want
to ask a question about the
configuration there um or not ask but
let you explain um scroll down uh scroll
down uh that one there uh tra
by side right yes this is for example Z
right but for example if you have here
three three consecutive Longs and I want
to take only the first long and the two
Longs I can type a two so I enter long
get the target enter long get the Target
and then it is ignored now I am waiting
for a short yeah yeah that's uh I think
that might answer that question a little
bit more because you know it's it's one
of those things where you know
sometimes you know if you're trying to
trade reversals right and you don't want
just sometimes you know I always say
take marketting context right so
obviously you want to be getting long
somewhere near the top of the move or
sorry get short somewhere near the top
get long somewhere near the bottom you
don't want to just keep selling selling
selling selling selling because
eventually you know after you got short
eight times it's it's going to run out
you know then find yourself short at the
bottom of the move but um you know for
some people I keep it set to zero um I
had tried setting it to you know another
number but then I just I just I for me
personally I keep it to uh to zero but
that in case anybody was wondering what
that was that's that's what that is um
another question can Mark excuse me
sorry can markers plus enter a trade on
a micro based on a signal in the mini
contract so for example Le um signal on
the gold Futures but uh enter a position
on the micro
gold yes because all the variables all
the
variables and all the
signals are um Global per instrument
that means go long with this ID exist on
all your charts for the same instrument
for Nasdaq
but if you have another instrument so
you want signals on one place and
Trigger ER orders on another instrument
you can
add the
global the this
signal and of course when you copy you
need to create global
by by the way H this will be the case
where you are copying on one chart with
one instrument and placing the
markers automation tool on another chart
with a different instrument so go long
is created on I don't know
maybe the standard instrument and Q and
markers is placed on on the mini M and
Q This is a classic
okay so how would you just real quick um
so how how would it know to enter say
okay so like right now your chart is uh
NQ how would it tell it to enter
mnq um very simply I I remove marker
from here
okay so now NASDAQ and this chart n is
only doing the copy
Okay so
now when the indicator has a
value the variable go long which is
global has value so now you go to
another chart ah okay I am on playback
so I I don't have data for M and Q but
let's say we can
try and
Futures you
minutes or it doesn't matter now with
the time frame because markers is just
going to execute
right okay yes I havea perfect so now I
only need to add
markers the time frame is not necessary
to be the same so Place
markers uh fast signal
mode and and take a look at the global
go long Global go short right and that's
all ah okay yeah so you got have
basically two charts open one running
the copy on the market that you want to
copy from one the signal and the other
is executing the sign right gotcha
gotcha makes sense now um couple
questions
uh one for me why get order flows 3.0
get the scaler well orderflow itself is
you know such a
big thing as opposed to orderflow
scalper reads the order flow in general
there's a lot of other nuances in the
order flow that's not covered um by the
scalper uh let's see
here someone's asking if we got the
discount yeah I'll go over that uh a
little bit later um yes there will be a
recording
um Jeffrey asks if we buy the indicator
will there be a template
yeah I'm GNA
do I'm
gonna I have a chat room where I am of
all the common indicators
so got on his site he's got a bunch he's
also got a Discord group um you guys are
are interested in that um let's see
here Peter asks if I buy markers is
there
coaching or only
videos um that's talked
to we we we have the chat room open 247
okay and we have
free training sessions all
Tuesdays and also we have advanced
sessions but I suggest doing first the
the basic tration because the Advan is
really Advanced yeah the
uh the Discord group you know I mean
it's it's it's a great good resource um
you know to ask questions and find out
from other people what's working um is
there a way to use a strategy
analyzer um help reviewing targets and
stops you know this is what this is what
I explain on the Advan because we know
that strategy analyzer uses standard
orders
and here we are using ATM orders the
strateg analyzer is not compatible with
ATM
but on the advanced sessions all
Saturdays I am explaining how to convert
a a logic that we have on on markers to
create a strategy with Builder and then
optimize the
parameters okay okay yeah you know the
problem with optimizing anything is it
tends to be curve fitted a lot of times
and and and that's a problem especially
when it comes to trading because you
know sometimes people optimize optimize
optimize and a this is it I got the the
the perfect setting well yeah it was the
perfect setting for everything up to
right now um going forward then they
wonder why everything failed you know
because obviously the markets um keep
changing but uh there's another question
Nick asks is there a step-by-step
tutorial well you know I'm going to show
you um after I get through these
questions how how easy it is to set up
um pull up a chart start from scratch
can it be used on a wrinkle chart I
don't think so I don't use wrinkled
charts um Pablo what's your experience I
I know my I don't think my indicator can
be used on a wrinkled chart honestly I
haven't looked at it but um I don't I'm
not sure in relation to markers there's
no importance on the time frame because
it's just look signals and execute
signals right okay um Eugene asks is
trade executed automatically when the
signal appears or should be entered
manually um well there's different modes
use the automatic mode it'll be
automatic um yes at the exact tick the
signal is painted it enters the market
and so you have the option to leave the
system to enter the trade at the exact
moment by you and then you can take
control this is my suggested method let
the system enter the trade and then you
take control and move the Target and the
stops to the most appropriate position
taking into account your support and
resistance
right um hang on a second here I got a
couple questions for me um
Rob nextg Trader I I'll check my email I
didn't get an email from you recently
I'll check again also uh JRP 4605 I'll
send you an email um let me see here
when I get a long signal is it possible
for markers to open only open a position
of that long signal is on a green bar
and vice versa short signal only want
markers to submit an order if that
signal is on a red bar so basically I
guess he's asking say he gets a signal
but he only wants to take it on a green
bar like a Buy Signal on a green bar and
a sell signal on a red bar is there a
way to do that in markers yes you you
only need to
set as we did
here my filter will be that the body
green or that I have two consecutive vs
in green example
uh where is my Mark I deleted markers
from this chart but it remains on this
one I can place a filter like
this I go to
filters and for
Longs I want a green bar for example the
close on the current bar is greater than
the open on the corrent bar this is a
green bar because the close is over the
open
this is
for for Longs and even more if you want
to enter long only if the current bar is
green and also the previous is green you
can type that the close one was greater
than the open one that means P bar is
green previous bar was green right this
is just a classic filter okay so you use
filters for that um another question is
if better with markers plus if my
indicator generates a plot like a
triangle or is it better if it generates
a text plot like go long go
short it doesn't matter yeah it doesn't
matter what whatever it does as long as
it plots something yeah I I suggest
using a plot yes yeah right um question
here for me
hin I'll check my email I'll check your
I'll check your license um hin and get
back to you
um
Roberts uh
question well this is kind of a general
question for me which markets do you
find this works best on E Minis and Q
you
know this is the question you know I I
don't really trade NQ I do follow it I
trade es you know NQ moves are just too
fast for me um you know and then at the
same time for other people they love inq
because they love that volatility but it
does work on NQ you know I have a user
who's using it on NQ and he's telling me
it's it's he's been seeing phenomenal I
have a I have a comment about that oh I
I was looking at the indicator and the
signals are much better on standard PS
but the reason because I did this is
because the number of ticks on standard
and PO is huge it is much more than
NASDAQ so trying to trying to do this
webinar will be impossible from my
notbook
yeah that's the only reason it's it's
funny you know I I just for me it's it's
about trading in a market that's easier
to trade um you know because there's you
know besides the e- minis you know I
trade some commodity markets that for me
it's just it's just easier honestly um
you know the markets move more
methodically NASDAQ you get a lot of up
and down up you know 20 points in in 30
seconds in the NASDAQ you know it's
going to give me a hard give you a heart
attack you know but uh again that that
that just comes down to you but there
are people I know that trading NASDAQ
that are doing really well they sent me
some very um reassuring emails that uh
it does work on NASDAQ you know for me I
I just want the path of least resistance
you know I just want a market that isn't
going to stress me out too much and you
know is going to move nicely rather than
erratically um have you found a favorite
setting yet and if so what are your
average gains yeah you know in the
previous presentation I did um I I go
over some settings but again you know it
depends on how you trade yourself you
know do you want a lot of signals do you
want less signals um let me see okay
this question I'll answer does flow
scalper dep depict signals at the close
of a bar that momentarily disappear
while the bars are forming now again on
Flow scalper there's a there's a setting
called trade entry signal trade entry
signal means the bar has to if you have
it enabled the bar has to close and once
the bar closes once it prints then
that's it the signal will appear if you
do not have trade entry signal
enabled as the bar is forming it's right
here in the middle right so if that's
enabled the bar has to close and the
next bar or two has to move two ticks in
the direction of the signal if it is
disabled as the bar is forming the
signal can print and unprint depending
on what's happening in that bar and for
some people they prefer some people like
to just see the signal as soon as it
forms and you know because they're more
on pure scalping and so they're you know
happy to take signals intra bar back and
forth and they're reading the order flow
now for people that tend to be more
indicator Centric they don't want it to
reprint and that's where're using the
trade entry signal is going to going to
help you um is orderflow scalper this is
next question from me flow
scalper a light version of order flow 3
not really um I said it it's it
reads overall it reads the orderflow but
again in orderflow there's a lot of
little
nuances um technical can you offer
technical help to set up but I'm about
to just go over really quick um how to
set it up it'll just take a couple
minutes uh Pablo see Michael
uh yeah there there'll be a template I
know Pablo's got templates um on his
website and I'll put one up on my
website
uh see here templates
templates
[Music]
um yeah again you know there a couple
questions what's the difference between
orderflow scalper and orderflows 3.0
orderflow scalper is an indicator that
reads the orderflow orderflows 3.0 is
the footprint chart um
okay yeah Peter Peter asked me about a
second license yeah Peter
I'll if if if you know the way the
licenses work just um you know people
understand on my indicators it's linked
to the machine ID that's on your
computer from Ninja Trader so if you
have more than one
computer you're going to need more than
one license Pablo I'm G to take the
screen back from you
um
[Music]
okay
yeah okay
here okay there we go can can you see my
screen
now should be able to I can see your
screen okay
um okay
let me see
here okay so I just going to show you
guys really quick I'm going to start
from scratch okay so really quick while
while I got you here this is a footprint
chart obviously this is a bar chart um
footprint chart this is the order flow
Trader 3.0 right the flow scalper reads
what's in here and gives you signals
based on a form of analysis of the
footprint chart okay but the order flows
Trader does more it it shows you like
the value areas of the bars the points
of control um you know the certain
points of control that are bullish like
this one here is a very bullish point of
control that's why it's why it's green
um all you know the different types of
analysis that I use in in trading
doesn't all go exactly into the flow
scalper a lot of it does but not every
single little thing because there's just
so much that's going on anyway um I will
just show you guys real quick how how
easy it is to set up
um markers okay I'll just open up a new
Scrat a chart from scratch so yeah I
like to put tick replay on Pablo went
through a little trick a little hack so
to speak um where you don't need tick
replay but I'll just put up a simple
chart here um just change some of the
colors uh
AIS is
black Crosshair in case I need to use is
it I'll make that
black okay so there's a few steps
there's only about six steps that that I
go through here um I also turn on chart
Trader I like to show date and range on
my chart um chart Trader okay so that's
this part over
here uh okay so right now I've got Delta
scalper on this chart let me just take
it
off all right
so let
I'll put on Flow
scalper this is e mini so for this
presentation I'll just use the the
defaults that I have for my flow scalper
which is zero no swing filter five and
no contango
um typ market I'll put that on I have
trade entry signal on and I'll click
apply okay and while that's coming up
I'll start
adding uh markers
Force um copy one for the buys one's for
the sells
okay um so what I'm going to do first do
I'll go to markers the force just make
this a little bit
bigger uh so yeah I want to
enable Longs enable shorts I'll make it
fast signal so you can see go long go
short um again you could sort of name it
whatever you want in this case I'll use
normal
up for long signals for short signals
I'll call it normal
down
um what else in
here 500's in this market nowadays 500's
a little um a little tight uh you so you
might want to make it a little bigger a
thousand or something it depends on how
much you're
trading and working mode uh change to
Auto okay so basically four things
working mode Auto enable Longs enable
shorts fast signals enable I Chang the
name of the fast signals normal up and
normal down in this case and I just
changed this part here the the Longs and
the shorts now I got to set up the Buys
so the first
one will be the uh Buys so what I'm
going to do is I'll change this right
because it says my line
change it to normal
up and I'm going to use fast
signal and where are we here this one
the data series is where I find the
indicator little scalper I check these
to make sure this is the right
settings five is enabled everything else
not tight markets all enable plot right
the normal Buy Signal
okay okay Jeffrey says change uh normal
up all right let me take a look
here so that's it there
[Music]
and now again
if normal here normal normal
thanks thanks Jeff um again how you want
it to plot if you know you could have
the dot so it'll tell you you know Pablo
showed you the dot or you can change it
to you know what the signal is if you
want to have it different it doesn't
matter in this case I'll just keep it as
the dot so
then um hit apply so now I got to set up
the
cell the cell um the cell copy
so I'm going to change that to normal
down enable fast
signal oh Sor I got to change this part
to
ontick
[Music]
and since it's a cell yeah you probably
want to change it to a red
color so I got everything right here
signal down change H tick normal cell
signal normal down click apply I forgot
this one I got to change
to on each
tick and the input series of the second
marker copy input
Series yeah that's very important
trying to run through it really fast uh
they should all be the same here F 5 Z
do
tight okay normal
s the other
plot which one the the plot on the into
serious on this one or in this one the
actual in here and on the left
one it's normal oh oh yeah yeah yeah
cell signal that little pot there so
that little piece that I'm trying to go
through I'm trying to make it fast you
know one steps
um and that's that's that so you see
it's calculating here so because I have
tick data enabled again Pablo showed you
a little hack to get around that but um
you it's pretty quick and then what you
got to do while that's sort of going on
you make sure your ATM is is selected
you know selected valid you see selected
valid ATM up up
here um you know for e- minis during the
day I like to use 16 by 16 um I click
that so you see 16 by
then make sure your account is set play
back okay so play back up here make sure
that matches there
Auto U make sure that's enabled for auto
mode and then um you just basically then
you
can start it up here let me get my this
is just from Friday here make it a
little faster
but so you can see you know if there's
one thing to keep in mind
right hang on a second here under the
flows
the force
rather
um enable reversals Okay so if you're in
a position and another signal comes up
it will close out the position enter
into the new position um some people I
use that you know some people may not
want to use it so again it's up to you
but uh you have that that option
anyway um so you can see like even if it
doesn't hit your Target and it does the
reversal it'll just get you out on once
the new
uh once it gives you that new
signal so me again the way I use it is I
manage the trade um I use it to get in I
I don't just either let it go directly
to my um Target or or stop
now again what Pablo was talking about
earlier just really
quick um under this part
here where is it where am I trades per
side setting it to zero so like you
could see here right there was short in
here or here then you know the take
profit was here but there was another
short signal here so it got me short
again another short signal got me short
again if you set it at say you set it at
one it would only take you know the
first trade until a Buy Signal came in
um so again you know just bear that in
mind if if you're wondering how how to
use that
part so you know it said you saw how
quickly I was able to set it up I'm
going to put this checklist I'm going to
send this list out you know I have it
all written down honestly um so you can
see how you know literally it's six
steps and you just go through that I'll
send it out with the replay you know
because I'm sure people will ask how do
I how do I you know set it up um you
know because again you know sometimes
people think it's very complicated it's
really not you just go through a simple
checklist and and and go from there um
people are asking is there a discount um
well right now I have the flow scalper
as until the end of this next week um is
its price is actually going to go up I
have it a very introductory price right
now but at I have one more presentation
later this week coming up um with
investors Expo which I'll be dealing
with flow scalper so right now it's 349
but in after Martin Luther King Day it
price will will increase so if you
already have a copy you want another
copy I do offer a discount
um now Pablo what about you what can you
do for people as far as uh you know you
got any special deal or anything yes of
course of course yes we we have a a very
interesting C coupon of this comp okay
um if you are registered to this list of
course
right okay so anyway um for me just go
to flow scaler.com you're still going to
get the introdu trory price and you know
what if you're watching this
presentation even after I raised the
price shoot me an email um you know I
know sometimes you know people they get
paid at you know weekly some people get
paid monthly I know when I lived in
Singapore they got paid monthly so
sometimes I gota wait till the in a
month to buy something but you know if
you watch this presentation and you want
to sort of lock it in just shoot me an
email say hey Mike you I watched your
presentation with Pablo uh just for
whatever reason um wasn't able to get it
at that time you know can you
work out something for me yeah just you
know just shoot me an email so for now
for me go to flow scaler.com Pablo if
you want um you can take over the screen
back I'll put your link up there
okay or I could give you back the screen
here uh there you
go which screen uh this one
and for those who don't know
me this is my web
page and indicator
market.com and the chat room is at the
bottom here you only need to click on
connect if you already have a Discord
account then you just click on connect
and you are in
if you never use a Discord before then
you get a a page to create an
user and inside the the chat room you we
have several let me show
you how is
Discord
okay this is my
this is how Discord
looks and these are all the sections
that we have we have a special section
for markers users where you can post
questions we have templates
also and not only my templates everyone
is H posting templates and trying to
help other
users H you you can contact me just if
you enter on the general section
you can click over my name and type a
question and you and you talk directly
with me this is anytime because this is
on my
mobile and that's all you can find on
from my chat room you can find
everything that you need and to access
my chat room you only need to go to my
website go to the bottom and click on
connect okay
so it's the indicator market.com right
exactly okay hly I get a little confused
the indicator Market the indicator store
no if you if you if you type
the store.com you go to the same place
right right okay I'll put it in the chat
there for everybody there you
go and you can see there you can get
markers Plus what's the difference
between markers plus and markers light
no this is not currently not available
okay gotcha just save you a question or
two
later so anyway we thanks Pablo um
thanks everybody you know it's it was a
big
uh a big ask for people to come out on a
Saturday morning um you know then spend
an hour and 40 minutes with us so again
you know any questions for me shoot me
an email um I got a few people here
wrote down Rob JRP Peter and hin I I'll
get back to you and again if you got any
questions for Pablo you know his Conta
you can contact me on the chat room or
my email is
Pablo the indicator
store.com right and that's that's also
on his website as well um
so thanks everybody um thanks for taking
that time out today um thanks Pablo for
your time I think this thank you this
really helps a lot of people and you
know that's the whole point of of it to
do um you know is to expand people's
knowledge on really what's available out
there you know because a lot of people
don't realize you know there's there's
these tools out there that can
facilitate their trading um you know and
and ultimately you know become a better
Trader so thanks Pablo thanks everybody
for attending and there will be a replay
I'm going to uh after this is done I get
go through render it and stuff so it'll
be up later today um and I'll send out a
link to you guys with how I set up
markers um and all the contact
information for Pablo as well so thanks
everybody and have a great uh rest of
the weekend thanks Pablo thank you
everyone have a great weekend bye bye
bye bye